so we took sheriff apart the other day
and one of the things we saw in there
was that they had this back play which
all the cards connected to so what I
thought we'd do is actually to have a
look at how a backplane works and how it
interconnects all the different cards to
form a complete computer system and what
it will actually show us is how any
computer works it doesn't matter whether
it's using a motherboard like a
traditional computer or a backplane
system or computers while this all
computers up to the Pentium era are
connected in this sort of fashion we see
the backplane physically what it
actually looked like diagrammatically is
you've got a PCB and you've got various
sockets on it and these are all
interconnected you also have some
resistors on there and probably some
capacitors to smooth the power supply
and to terminate the ends of the bus but
effectively you've got a series of
connectors which the cards can slide
into and everything is then
interconnected so what sort of things
are connected over those first of all if
we have a look over here I have a
descendant from one of the original
Acorn system cards this is a control
Universal euro Beebe card but he's is
the same backplane technology as the
Acorn system used so originally all
you've got areas of pins and when you
plug these into the backplane they just
connect up with the socket and then any
data or anything we sent down these
wires connect you talk to any other
cards so effectively what are you going
to send over the backplane what's
basically the signals from your CPU so
you've got a six 8,000 CPU here actually
took it out of an old lady writer
printer and coming out of this you have
an address bus and we've talked about
this before and you have a data bus and
the data bus is bi-directional so I'm
just going to move the trip a bit so I
can actually sort of draw another arrow
so we've got an address bus and we going
to date with and the way the CPU works
is a few other control signals which go
over there as well which we'll ignore
for now is when every wants to talk to
anything in the computer inputs on the
address there and that's just a number
so we have something get addressed
one zero one zero one zero and it will
say I want to read that address I want
to write that address and if it's
reading it than the data sent that way
if it's writing it that it writes the
data out all that goes over your
backplane effectively along with the
control signals is the address bus and
the data bus if you look carefully you
can see them coming off the CPU here
being can
directly to the pins on the backplane
connector now this is a bit odd if you
look at the original schematics for the
Acorn system one you'll see that they
had a whole load of buffer chips we
should make sure you've got a strong and
stable signal out over the backplane bus
one of the problems when designing these
sort of things is that the voltage that
comes out of the CPU or microprocessor
is struggling off the drive and
motherboard when you got two going over
a back plane or something you probably
want a buffer there to give a bit more
strength to the signal so it can talk to
the other things and they would have
buffers so that when they send to me
back the data didn't get caught because
he was travelling along the relatively
long wide if you look at the Sun system
again you see we have quite a wide
backplane so let's have a look at our
backplane so we've got two things we've
got an address bus which we'll call LED
dr and we have a database and we'd also
have an alarm which as a control bus
which is also be there it says whether
you're reading or writing what type of
data triaxis and so on we're going to
ignore that for now
but it would be there as well and it
connects up in exactly the same way so
if we wanted to build up a system with
the backplane there we just sliding the
cars and effectively all you're doing is
connecting that device to the address
bus and the database so we started off
with a CPU card and so we've got a CPU
there and that connects to the address
bus and it connects down to the data bus
like that now we also want some other
things in there we want to be able to
use the system to probably some memories
so we'd have a RAM card and again that
connects to the address bus and it
connects to the data bus probably opting
out from there we had a scuzzy card in
there and this again connects to the
address bus and it connects to the data
bus and of course because it's scuzzy
it's got a connection to the hard disk
as well as a separate connection and the
files and CPUs concerned only see the
scuzzy card and then the discovery card
talks to the hardest so he sort of talks
indirectly and you could put whatever
else you wanted on there so we could
have an Ethernet card now cause there's
nothing to stop the cards having other
things there if we look to the CPU card
that we had before in the Sun system it
had the CPU on there but it also had
four Meg of RAM and it also had an
Ethernet controller and some serial port
so the card can be
multifunction but in effect
as far as we're concerned here we're
treating is one thing now they're
connected to the address bus and the
connected to the data bus so how do they
communicate well they all communicate
over the data but that's where the data
sent but you need to make sure that only
one thing is communicating at a time
otherwise you'll get a garbled signal on
there and you wouldn't know what's
happening so the way that the CPU does
that is it make sure everything has a
unique address and so one of the things
that you need to do is make sure that
the RAM is only accessed when you've got
one address on there because he's only
accessed when you've got another address
on there and so on depending on what you
need to do so how did you get it about
doing that so we look at a real computer
system here now this wasn't a back
playing basic computer this was the
Atari ST book laptop so it's also to
combine onto one motherboard but the
principles are same the difference
between this and the Sun is it with the
Sun you could swap the components around
as you please to choose it with a laptop
having a huge cards and there would
perhaps be a little cumbersome so
everything was built on to the one
motherboard so the first thing we see
when we look at it is that you dress
buses and the date was in some cases the
dress buttons are different sizes the
CPU like these six 8,000 we have here
has a 24-bit address but now because
it's a 16-bit CPU or present the 16-bit
data but you only have 23 address bus
pins that you need to take out of it so
it's labeled 23 here so we've got 23
bits worth of address space we can
access that 16,777,216 bytes worth of
memory or hardware whatever you want to
put in there now as we go through we can
see the other things that are connected
so for example we have a system ROM but
this only uses 18 bits worth of address
space it's got 18 bits the meeting
control on the machine and you use two
bits worth as did the keyboard
controller the sound chip
they only been drawn on the address
connection there but probably only uses
two bits worth there if I remember right
destroy it in slow one - Charlie went
bus if they didn't draw their diagrams
properly this one was an interrupt and
multifunctional device it used five bits
that's 32 bytes worth of address space
and so on so how does it work well the
basic principle is that you decide what
you want to go where in your computer so
with something like the Atari they
decided that if this was the memory will
use hexadecimals like 16 Meg's and
zero they said right the first four
megabytes are going to be Ram so any
address between zero and what's four
megabytes is hex I think that's four
zero zero zero zero zero I may have an
extra zero in there but it's about that
sort of value so that's going to be
round to any address in this range we're
going to say is around what they also
said is that anything roughly and for
the chart Rams in there I am waving my
hand so all the hardware things are
going to go up there and then you had
your ROM trip which started at E 0 0 0 0
0 and that's got the operating system in
so what we can see from this is
different addresses different numbers of
the location refer to different things
so as far as the CPUs concerned we put
an address on the address bus and we're
talking to something else we put a low
address we're talking to Ram could put a
high address we're talking to hardware
and so on so what the computer has to do
in fact what every single card has to do
in a batplane system like this is look
at the address on the address bus and
decide whether it's an address that's
accessing it whatever it provides or
whether it's an address for something
else which case it ignores it and how to
do that one way I think it's really
helpful to see how this works is to look
at phone number so in the UK we might
have a phone number like this which we
familiar to anyone of a certain age in
the UK anyone have an older age maybe
expect me to written oh one eight one
one eight zero five five hello great
good morning to us just reading one of
the morning papers anyway doesn't matter
there's the collection of numbers in
this case they are 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
digits on they can vary computer
addresses are a fixed number of binary
digits the analogy works but this number
isn't just a series of digits it's made
up of two parts we have an area code or
STD code as a known in the UK and then
the phone number within that exchange in
this case we can split it like this and
this is s TD code and this is the rest
of the number and what happens when you
dial in to swap shop is you Dan that
number the first two digit tells the
exchange that you want to connect to the
London exchange and then coax the London
exchange with other exchanges the rest
of the number
to connect you to the BBC and hopefully
you get through to speak to no Redmon's
but for the younger UK audience
obviously as TV colors have changed a
lot since 1980 yeah so yeah this is what
they were up in the 1980 now Sean
rightly points out we can change this it
doesn't have to be this and actually in
the late 80s they would change so they
were actually o8 one and so you had to
change the exchanges to recognise that
prefix and then they could use the rest
of it but this bit didn't change and
it's exactly the same with our computer
system so our computer system has an
address say for the ROM chip and in this
case it's going to access in binary one
one one do it which is he and
hexadecimal and then some more digits
and we'll just fill these zeros kept
running out of space it's a this is why
we use hexadecimal when we're doing
computer systems because binary numbers
take up but as far as the computer is
concerned it works exactly the same
principle as the phone numbers and the
phone number this is the bit that refers
to something in the London exchange and
it's refers to the London exchange the
computer works in the same way this bit
refers saying this means it's wrong and
this fit tells you where it is in the
wrong now I can change this by just
making the computer look for a different
number here and so what you need to do
is have some sort of logic and because
these are zeros or one they can be
treated as digital logic to or false and
Saunders true when that number is one
when that number is one when that number
is one and that number is zero or not
one and you add them all together and if
that's true you know you're talking to
wrong now if you've got a different
number here say we're talking to
Hardware one one one one
sort of like that the longview numbers
are unique you can access different
things so all you have in your system
connecting everything together is on
each of these cards you have a bit of
logic which will look at part of the
address on the address bus a certain
number of bits and say is this the
address that's been assigned to me for
this card yes it is
therefore the address and the data on
the address bus are from my car
odd if not been there for one of the
other cars and ignores it so they'll be
a bit of logic there that says is this
the address I've been assigned if it is
I'm going to handle it if it isn't then
I'm not going to handle it something
else can deal with it and if we have a
look at one of the cards if we pull a
card out of the system so this is from a
sundry 160 server and it's got an
Ethernet connection on the back those
are some free wide euro cards if you
look the connectors are the same as the
one we had earlier but if you look these
three rows of pins in there and two rows
here but if you look here you've got a
series of chips and still given dust and
a series of dip switches that enable you
to program in a specific address and
that will then set where littles here in
the computer's memory and so you can
then pop that back into the system and
it would allow you to talk to the second
ethernet card so this approach works
great on something like the Sun 3160
where you're going to mix and match
cards to build a bespoke system the
works adjust exactly as you want it so
you put in the ethernet cards you want
the scuzzy cards the RAM attention to be
consistent but actually the same is true
on the original IBM PC system so we look
at the kit IBM PC I've got here you had
a series of five is a as they became
known extension cards where you could
put in different cards to build up your
system these are the spaces here and you
were just literally slotting cards like
this one here which was a network card
actually slightly later on so it's got a
16 bit extension but this was the
original card thing here and this again
have settings where you can set the
address where you want to appear in the
member now the PC is a bit more
complicated as well as having an address
space like the Motorola chips it also
has an i/o address space and so you
could actually things in two different
ways but the same principle applies and
so you would then just swap these in and
it will just connect up the address
buffers and the data buses and the
control buses in the same way now the
interesting thing is that there's no
reason why the rest of the components
couldn't have been on ISA cards as well
the only reason they aren't is that most
people are going to buy a computer like
an IBM PC are going to buy
one with a CPU with RAM and so on so
it's just easy to put them all on the
mainboard and then you have a mini
backplane equivalent here you could
slaughtering the Extension cards whether
you wanted a monochrome graphics card or
a color at the time hard disk control
the floppy disk controller serial port
parallel port etc etc you have a same
amount of flexibility the difference was
if you wanted to replace the CPU card in
that you just slip the card out but a
better one in Turner to place the CPU on
here
you'd effectively have to replace the
whole motherboard and it got a lot more
messy but it's a different use cases you
don't expect people to buy a computer
ready built and perhaps add an extra
card if they needed a network someone
buying this knew exactly what it wanted
to do and configured it to their own
specification and when you're going to
finish this IBM PC yeah that's a good
question when I got some time to get
soldering and stop rebuilding older
systems now you're probably thinking I
just slot my car PCI card into the
computer and it just works well the
trick there is that what they're
actually doing is that they're working
out the address of where things are
based on which card is an automatically
assigning addresses and then FAQ
producing away the sort of plug-and-play
idea that the computer can automatically
configure itself for the same effective
idea each card will have a unique
address and then they'll be accessed of
course on a modern PC today the bus
systems that are used look more like
network connections and they do address
buses and data buses but they're still
accessed from the software point of view
in the same way
[Music]
could you